[Music]
there are two things we can always count
on the first is that disney will keep
churning out star wars content until the
end of time there could be an
apocalyptic you know asteroid strike
that destroys all life on earth except
cockroaches and bacteria and yet still
somehow they'd find a way to release a
new star wars spin-off series for the
unrighteous even death cannot save you
as i'm quite certain that they have star
wars playing on a loop in hell at least
if i go to hell that's gonna be my hell
i'm quite certain of it the other
inevitability um
so routine and frequent that we can set
our watches by it
is that hollywood actresses will pretend
to be traumatized by mild criticism
so those are the two things and
sometimes these two phenomena will merge
combining their powers to create a sort
of megazord of cringe and that's what's
happened with the actress moses ingram
who though her parents apparently named
her moses is indeed a female she's also
black and she stars as a villain in the
new obi-wan kenobi tv series because of
course even though the original star
wars characters were mostly
one-dimensional and poorly written
uh they all for some reason need their
own shows to flesh out their incredibly
uninteresting backstories ingram's
villain i'm told by the site screen rant
is named
riva savander slash
third sister
not sure what that means exactly i'm
also confused by this part of the of the
same screen rant article which says
quote with her role in obi-wan kenobi
ingram truly is breaking new ground for
the star wars franchise she'll stand
among
one of the few female villains and also
one of the few women of color with a
prominent role ingram's determination to
give children of color a character they
can see themselves in
is admirable and also demonstrates just
how important representation is
wait a second
so we want black children to see
themselves in
the villain of the story
is racial equity among super villains
really important
have young minority children suffered
some sort of deprivation due to a lack
of evil fictional character
representation apparently so
but evidently not all of the star wars
fans are appreciative of this new
character or of the fact that disney is
worried about including characters just
for the sake of racial representation
some of these fans have reportedly sent
some unpleasant messages to ingram
herself who was johnny on the spot with
the victimization narrative i mean she
was ready to go
as soon as those first few messages came
in she was ready
and so she posted an instagram video
sharing a few pieces of the hate mail
which if real i read i read them and um
the ones that she provided and
if they're real they're rude
sure but they're not even close to the
level of hate mail that somebody like
myself receives on a daily basis
nonetheless ingram um
showed the hate mail and then gave this
responses
long story short
um
there are hundreds of those
hundreds
um
and i also see those of you out there
who put on a cake for me
and that really does mean the world to
me because
you know
there's nothing anybody can do
about this
there's nothing anybody can do
to stop this hate and so i question what
my purpose is and even being here in
front of you
saying that this is happening
i don't really know
i don't really know
um
but i think the thing that bothers me
is that like
sort of this feeling that i've had
inside of myself
which no one has told me but this
feeling of like i just gotta shut up and
take it you know i just kind of got a
green and buried um
and i'm not built like that so
i really just wanted to come on i think
and say thank you to the people who show
up for me in the comments and the places
that i'm not gonna put myself
um to the rest of y'all
y'all weird
now you know there was a time when
celebrities would
get a bit of hate mail you know they've
always gotten hate mail anybody in the
public eye has always gotten hate mail
and they would just move on with their
lives they didn't feel the need to give
it the time of day if you're a hollywood
actress it's pretty much guaranteed that
99.999 percent of the communication you
receive on a daily basis will consist of
fawning
praise but why say anything at all about
the .0001
exception
well because everybody's looking to be a
victim even and especially hollywood
actresses and everybody surrounding the
actress is looking to be a white knight
virtue signaling like you and mcgregor
the star of obi-wan kenobi who recorded
this message of support listen
it seems that some of the fanbase from
this influential fan base
have decided to attack moses ingram
online and send her the most horrendous
racist dms
and i hired some of them this morning
and it just broke my heart
moses is a brilliant actor she's a
brilliant woman
and she's absolutely amazing in this
series
first of all ewan mcgregor doesn't know
the first thing about car videos and
this is this is a an actor
terrible cinematography there compared
to at least what what you got from me
back in the old days did it really break
your heart though ewing really i mean we
just had a school shooting in texas
where 19 children were slaughtered but
you had time to feel heartbroken
because an actress got a few mean dms
the official star wars twitter account
got in on the action too posting this
we're proud to welcome moses ingram to
the star wars family and excited for
riva's story to unfold if anybody
intends to make her feel in any way
unwelcome we have only one thing to say
we resist
there are more than 20 million sentient
species in the star wars galaxy don't
choose to be a racist
so brave so bold
disney will edit their movies to appease
to the chinese market but when it comes
to standing up against a smattering of
random twitter accounts
they're downright courageous admirable
although the interesting thing here is
that
under this tweet from star wars account
lots of actual star wars fans are
publicly explaining why they don't like
ingram's character and it has nothing to
do with race it turns out
according to these fans the character is
poorly written poorly acted unlikable
and is a kind of mary sue character who
can do anything and possesses arbitrary
powers that exist as plot devices more
than anything else now i haven't seen
the show and i never will see it so i
don't know if these criticisms are valid
i strongly suspect they are but i don't
know
i do know though that these are the
criticisms because i can read
and disney can read too
in fact disney knows that it created yet
another lame uninteresting unlikable
terrible character
and it knows that fans will hate her
and it has planned ahead of time to
create this racism narrative
which brings me to the real point
which is this
please stop watching
this stuff
stop watching star wars
the people creating this content hate
you
they will insult you to your face
they call you racism i mean that's the
guy the star of the show oh the racist
fan base
that's how they feel about you
they set up these traps so that they can
virtue signal off of your dislike of the
crappy characters they create
now look
it would be one thing if the people
behind star wars hated you and yet still
put out great content
and told worthwhile stories and
exhibited artistic brilliance
okay if the films and shows were high
quality
then i could even see why you might be
motivated to ignore their politics and
watch anyway
okay i could i could even i could i
could see that
potentially
but the content is garbage
they insult you not only by insulting
you but also by feeding you slop
none of the star wars content for the
past two decades was made because the
people making it really felt that these
stories needed to be told
it all simply exists to expand the brand
and earn money that's the only reason
the star wars story has been told they
finished telling it in 1983.
there's nothing else to tell
nothing else to say
and yet they keep talking why because
you'll pay for it
now
it's true that every film is supposed to
make money um everybody in the
entertainment business wants to make
money but
with disney and star wars not to mention
most superhero films
the money is the first last and only
consideration it's literally the only
reason any of this exists or continues
existing
this isn't art it's marketing these
aren't films they're commercials they're
not made by artists they're made by
teams of corporate drones
oh oh but the star wars universe is so
big you say there are so many stories in
the star wars universe no it isn't that
big apparently because it's been
repeating itself for 40 years
do you know what is big um
the actual universe
there are infinite stories to tell
in the universe
you could even tell stories about people
in space shooting laser beams at each
other i got no problem with that
i i like those kinds of stories
it doesn't have to have the star wars
label on it though
but they stick with that label because
it makes money and again
for no other reason
so it's time to end the cycle
stop letting these people disrespect you
drop star wars drop disney
subscribe to the daily wire instead
and don't miss the world premiere of my
new film what is a woman tonight at 8 pm
um you have no choice now anyway because
star wars is officially once and for all
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated